nine-one-one what's your emergency yes
major yeah so go out of the pool or rub
the flat I'll have a massive erection of
disorder or go want to write but the
woman to the house yeah is wearing get
this a chastity belt I want to talk
about Europe and did you K disarming the
populace entirely yeah because there are
two stories that came out today in the
last couple of days which I thought were
alarming so question question of the day
facts and stats that we've always talked
about this they don't exist in a vacuum
so we can compare violent crime
statistics gun control drug prices
things like at a certain point you do
have to decide would you rather live in
a european-style society that values the
collective welfare with admittedly
perhaps greater comfort or the American
model that values the individual and
rewards industriousness freedom versus
comfort freedom versus safety what would
you rather live in let's let's take away
the stats right now this is the macro
I'd like to hear some some comment so
where did this come from families in
Britain have been ordered by housing
officials to remove children's pools
from the gardens because burglars could
drown and that's true it's comes from
the Sun Whalers told residents they were
worried from worried from surrounding
area and potential burglars wandering
and at night could trip and fall in the
water so we bring this up because this
is what's actually happening in Europe
and we by the way we just so happen to
have a the nine the nine one one
exclusive of this cat burglars it did
happen dance with death exclusive
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's much better thanks Rob that fat
yeah radical your room yeah might be
right the woman it's a human right oh my
gosh by the way hit the notification
bell if you are subscribed because
apparently subscriptions don't mean
anything anymore and you'll be notified
on your phone or join Michael that's the
only way to get the full show every
single day you can talk about gun
control you all you okay
self-defense is illegal in the UK yep
let's just be flip down yeah it's the
illegal be honest you think that's moral
even if it resulted in significant death
reduction which it hasn't do you think
it's moral to outlaw the right to defend
oneself we have a few store this is been
going on for a while good example is an
English homeowner I had a toy gun a cap
gun I believe he detained two burglars
in his house while he called the police
the police arrested the homeowner for
the toy gun too it was used to threaten
or intimidate yeah oh yeah okay same
thing happened with other kappa so an
old lady she was arrested for putting
someone in fear when she scared off a
group of kids there were people charged
for self defense all the time in Europe
all the time and this is important
because I think this was a USA Today
article they were talking about how
there was a quote that said axe I get
accidental gun deaths in the United
States there's still a significant cause
of death period so if we look at the CDC
report in United States we 146,000
accidental deaths per year the top
things like you'd expect auto accidents
accidental poisoning is like 47,000 even
accidental hangings how do you do that I
don't know what's that I know one way
but I wouldn't think it result in sixty
nine hundred maybe going a little too
far
let's throw the parchment paper with
accidental discharge of firearms at 489
Wow that's almost remember it's actually
the least frequent cause on the CDC
lists oh my gosh now let's contrast that
with this this is why state doesn't
exist in a vacuum how many people who
are just I okay let start with this
arrests in the UK for nothing more than
speech thirty-three hundred people in
one year that's about nine people a day
for hate speech online a lot of time by
the way guy was jailed for singing kung
fu fighting charge for hate speech at a
karaoke bar that's reasonable that
actually really matters you know crime
interest got skyrocket yeah yeah I don't
think there's no crowd looks like that's
an American issue no no not at all not
at all here's the thing too like I say
there's a myth out there that it's the
choice between freedom or safety like
it's one or the other like of course
most people say well you know I would
give up a lot of freedom proceeding but
you see here it's neither or right you
don't get the freedom or the safety no
you don't get either either no both are
impossible to have it you especially I
mean just look at the violent crimes of
rapes across Europe in England in
particular like it's just it's awful
it's hard to look at those crimes
because it was important okay give you
an example let's say you don't follow
the gun manual and you accidentally
shoot yourself or the prospect of living
in a society where it is illegal to
protect yourself and your family from
violent criminals and this is why it
comes down to the society on what values
more the value of trying to ensure equal
outcomes or the value of your god-given
right to self-preservation this is what
it comes down to and two stories in 48
hours we said okay we're gonna have to
go back and revisit this look this up
look at the jailings for speech look at
people defending themselves and the
cases and the precedents set all across
Europe but specifically the UK it is
unreal when you're making people have to
second-guess whether they're gonna
protect their families they have no idea
what some intruders intentions are to
kill them to rape them to just steal
stuff from you they're in the wrong yeah
I have no idea look once you come in my
house at night uninvited and you don't
respond to me telling you to leave I'm
sorry but if you die and I live that's
fine
this is the one time where I say don't
advocate I advocate violence there's an
intruder in your house and you were in
the house and the intruder knows you're
in the house deal with it as swiftly and
as violently as possible period you
can't know if someone asks you to get
down on your knees and puts a gun to
your head you can't assume
he's had a rough day and he just wants a
corner just wants a 99-cent small chili
at Wendy's you've got to assume the guy
if he's want to put a gun to your head
is crazy enough to kill you it's not my
job it's not on you anymore the UK is
more concerned with protecting criminals
than allowing its citizens to protect
their families and there's a reason by
the way a prime of passion is treated
differently from a premeditated crime
okay this is a premeditated crime front
by the government against its people
this is spine-tingling level scale can
you imagine how I'm bold name to the
criminals this must be imagine you're a
criminal right now looking to looking to
do a home invasion you're going like
take away propose I said we never
problem with the pole he's called a
win-win I am no I am no where near as
concerned about an intruder the prospect
of an intruder and myself with a weapon
maybe a struggle ensues over the weapon
and yeah I get hurt versus a criminal
knowing they can come into my house live
in a society where they know they can
come into my house commit heinous crimes
and that there's nothing I can do about
it and if I try to do something about it
they'll see me in court and they'll
probably win yeah and you probably don't
have a gun to defend yourself anyway you
know good luck
that's why this is that's what would be
bothered when people talk about how they
have socialized that well that doesn't
exist in a vacuum it exists in the Ghul
if you look at the entire picture what
are you doing as far as National Defence
Canada can you protect your own border
that's not really how about the UK are
you inventing all the drugs when they
say well well we don't have to have a
kind of gun violence the everything I
say okay but what do you have instead of
that you have homeowners going to jail
for protecting themselves
you have skyrocketing rape and stabbings
mass stabbings by the way that's
stabbings it's a thing people being
stabbed this is what really bothered
when you whenever you're killing is a
killing spree in there yeah it's all
this breeze and this is why I don't know
what you think people who are just don't
like the European model I'm sorry and I
know some people do but when people act
there again about Americans as we are
who with guns I'd rather be a Yahoo with
a gun than a victim in a society that
sends me to jail for protecting my wife
from a rapist with a ceramic knife and
I'd rather be in a society that values
freedom and the rights of the individual
to over the collective rights of the
criminal
yes yeah
the house is wearing okay I'm police
have been dispatched need you to do a
stay and a safe place into the direction
hey if you liked this video subscribe or
click the notification but you should do
both anyways because youtube doesn't
notify you if your just subscribe you
have to hit that notification bell so if
you already are subscribed hit the
notification bell and if you're not
supporting this content go to lot or
credit outcome slash muck lip you get
the full nightly show an hour every day
free
when you subscribe this hand - courtesy
mug as well as other programming and
listen you also get to support not gay
Jared's Remicade treatment I don't know
what it is I know it has something
because he has yes he had all sort of
colitis it doesn't anymore thank God
because their mood is : and truth be
told it's not working very well anyway